while the pandemic is hurting many
industries demand for toilet paper
recently hit an all-time high a record
amount was produced in february and
march
more than 22 thousand tons a day
a recent report warns decades of
production has been destroying the
world's
largest untouched forest here in north
america the natural resources defense
council gave an
f to many u.s toilet paper brands
consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner shows what is happening
in the canadian boreal forest anna so
what did you learn
well good morning vlad you know
companies making toilet paper are
cranking out as much as they can
earlier this year production was up from
5 to 20 percent
but groups trying to protect natural
resources say that only heightens their
concern
for this forest to our north and what
they call the tree to toilet pipeline
this is a typical northern boreal forest
lots of spruce
this is an intact section of
forest here in the in the town of booze
today
we're visiting labrador canada with
valerie courtois a member of the
indigenous inu nation
the boreal is first and foremost home it
is
the forest where where we can be
the people that we are
[Music]
indigenous peoples like hers have
traditionally relied on the forest and
its woodland caribou for food
and spiritual sustenance but she says
both are threatened
we often say caribou and inu were one
and if the caribou were to disappear i
i honestly don't know what would become
of
of the inu people the boreal forest
stretches from canada's eastern shore
all the way to alaska
it keeps in millions of tons of carbon
which many scientists say without the
forest
would go into the atmosphere worsening
climate change
now in its issue with tissue report the
nrdc tells consumers
they're literally flushing those trees
down the toilet
nrdc's jennifer skeen each year
the logging industry in canada
clear-cuts over a million acres of the
boreal forest to create
products like toilet paper and this has
been going on for decades
the nrdc scored toilet papers and
flunked many popular products that used
virgin forest fiber
quilted northern angelsoft costco's
kirkland brand
sherman ultra scott 1000 and cottonell
ultra all scored
f's products getting a's used higher
percentages of recycled materials
good choices says the group assuming you
can find them
nrdc's shelley vineyard i hear a
consumer saying look
i'll take any kind of toilet paper i can
find right now
because i almost can't find any at all
what we
would say to that is of course you need
to have toilet paper
but the biggest makers of
tissue products in the united states are
making us unwittingly complicit
in fueling forest loss in canada that's
not an acceptable outcome
none of the leading toilet paper
manufacturers would speak on camera with
us for this story
but all said their products do not
contribute to deforestation
but there are other alternatives and as
you can see
it's nice and fluffy houston lifestyle
blogger joy green
switched to tp made from bamboo called
real
sold online i don't think there's much
sacrifice when you make the switch
p g maker of charmin says it's
researching alternative fibers but in a
letter to the nrdc
last year said recycled content results
in a substandard product
in the report nrdc accuses p g of green
flushing misleading the public with
green claims
but png says its toilet paper is sourced
from responsibly managed forests
and for every tree we use at least one
is regrown
they referred us to the certifying
organization fsc which sets forestry
standards
and its head francois dufresne who says
having png on board
is helpful having a large corporation
trying to do the right thing
on the ground is always positive but he
says in the future he does want
companies to value the forest role more
in protecting the planet so ultimately
you want a company like procter
gamble to gradually move away from using
virgin pulp from old growth trees in the
forest
over time it's the right thing to do and
increase
recycling content
well kimberly clark maker of scott and
cottonell said it will reduce its use
of virgin forest fiber by 50 by 2025 by
using recycled fiber
georgia pacific maker of quilted
northern and angelsoft
said it ensures fiber is responsibly
sourced
costco would not comment vlad
and i'm so glad you're highlighting uh
the peril that our forests
face because of deforestation it's such
a really important topic and i'm going
to switch to that bamboo toilet paper
special report to come maybe not all
right i want to hear a review
anna okay i'll text it to you
hannah warner we appreciate it thank you
very much